all right a lot of news tonight we still
have a lot to get to joining us now with
reaction the author of the number one
New York Times bestseller the Russia
hoax and the illicit scheme to clear
Hillary Clinton and frame Donald Trump
Fox News legal analyst Greg Jarrett and
the author of why we fight Fox News
national security strategist dr.
Sebastian Gorka dr. Gorka let me start
with you let's start with the big latest
lie of the media they all went with it
they never did their research and they
all basically like sheep follow each
other
it's remarkable Sean it shows you how
they have nothing let's be very clear
hopefully they're taking notes there is
no crime to meet with a foreign national
to obtain opposition research especially
when it turns out that that individual
took that meeting under false pretenses
however it is a crime it is a crime to
engage somebody at the cost of millions
of dollars who is not a foreign
registered agent but at the same time is
a former intelligence officer
that's Christopher Steele and to use his
Russian propaganda material as the
grounds for a surveillance warrant in a
FISA Court
Greg can give you all the chapters all
the code but that is a crime for the
last 430 days we have had zero evidence
shown connecting the president to Russia
and are going to say now on the record
they will never find any because there
isn't any well they haven't and the fact
is I played the tape of shyffilis ship
it's very hard to say on TV it's a very
risky move but in all seriousness Greg
okay he's talking to a Russian he's
getting op research that he hopes will
kill with off the president politically
and then we got Hillary's phony dossier
the media ignores it all Greg this is
beyond corrupt and they'll destroy the
president and his family in the process
with no compunction whatsoever
there's no fairness and equivalency I
was amazed today when the New York Times
in their front page story declared
without any evidence
without citing any statute that it was
illegal that trumped our meeting
well I'll cite the law the federal
campaign election Act specifically says
a foreign national may volunteer
services attend meetings and provide
information it is not and never has been
considered a thing of value under our
election laws what is a thing of value
is paying a foreigner as Hillary Clinton
did for information on Donald Trump that
didn't end then we learned the FBI also
paid him which we suspected now we know
that's right and the payment by Hillary
establishes it as a thing of value
making it illegal and yes as we learned
last Friday Judicial Watch through a
lawsuit obtained documents 11 from the
Department of Justice and the FBI which
shows the Christopher Steele was not
only on the payroll of Hillary Clinton
but for 7 months before the Trump Russia
case was officially launched he was on
the FBI's payroll receiving 11 payments
last word dr. Gordon Shore you mentioned
one thing that needs to be repeated
vessel it's kaya this private lawyer was
briefed by diffusion GPS before and
after the meeting in Trump Tower so this
could have been a setup from the get-go
all right thank you both